al presidente de la cámara de
representantes el republicano Kevin
mccarthy y el líder demócrata de la
cámara Jeffrey el líder de la mayoría
del senado y el líder también de La
minoría republicana en el senado para
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo y que los
republicanos que tienen mayoría en el
legislativo aprueben el aumento en el
límite de la deuda para evitar un de Fox
financiero la reunión duró cerca de una
hora y los republicanos que buscan
recortes radicales en el gasto del
Gobierno Federal no Salieron muy
esperanzados Kevin mccarthy tras la
reunión dijo que no vio ningún
movimiento nuevo para poner fin a un
estancamiento de meses sobre el aumento
del límite de endeudamiento por su parte
líder de La minoría republicana en el
senado dijo categóricamente que a pesar
del desencuentro Estados Unidos no va a
incurrir en un de fold financiero que
nunca lo ha hecho y no lo hará la
posición del presidente biden Es que
negociará la reducción del fiscal
siempre y cuando la posibilidad de esté
fuera de la mesa de negociación que los
republicanos la dejen de usar como un
arma la Casa Blanca dice además que esto
es muy riesgoso para la economía y los
mercados y que no hay Plan B por parte
de ellos recordemos que los republicanos
buscan recortes en el gasto eliminando
tensiones Fiscales para invertir en
energía limpia y revirtiendo los planes
de biden para reducir la carga de la
deuda de préstamos estudiantiles por su
parte biden Busca reducir el gasto
fiscal a través de aumentos a impuestos
a las personas ricos y cambios como
permitir que el gobierno negocie los
precios de los medicamentos recetados